foreign
the evolution of natural language
processing has come a long way today we
have a variety of AI language models
that are fully operational and have the
potential not just to decode your
question but also smart enough to
understand the intention behind your
questions are the countless number of
development and the emerging ones like
Megatron Albert Electra T5 and many more
these three models are currently ruling
the space of AI language models Bing
Bard and chargpt and today we will
understand the differences similarities
and the abilities that make them stand
out and try to decide which one is the
best hey everyone welcome to Simply
launch YouTube channel and today we
bring you the Bing versus the Google bar
the chat GPD but before we begin if
these are the type of videos you would
like to watch hit that subscribe button
and the bell icon to never miss an
update from Simply learn if you are an
aspiring artificial intelligence
engineer looking for an online training
and certification from the prestigious
universities and in collaboration with
leading experts so that you have the
most robust Foundation skills knowledge
and what it takes to become the best
then search no more simply learns post
graduation program in artificial
intelligence from Purdue University in
collaboration with IBM should be your
right choice for more details use the
link in the description box below also
want to get access to more informative
content like this one get subscribed to
us and hit the Bell so that you are the
first to get to know when we host with
that in mind let's start with the
elephant in the room that is the chat
gbd
was released on the 30th of November
2022 it uses the GPT llm to elaborate
llm as an abbreviation for large
language model and chat jpd is globally
available to its users using the
generative pre-trained Transformer also
called as chat GPT llm with one trillion
parameters as its variables loaned
during the model training now the Bing
Microsoft was one of the largest
investors in open AI Bing is an AI
language model created in collaboration
with open Ai and publicly released on
the 4th of May 2023 Beng uses the same
data set that chat GPT uses Bing has an
edge over chart GPT as Microsoft
integrates its Prometheus with about 135
billion parameters now next up we have
Bard Bart is Google's answer to chat gbd
with limited capabilities and lukewarm
responses it was released on 21st of
March 2023 but initially started off
with Lambda llm with a caliper of 137
billion parameters Google's CEO Esurance
Bard will switch to pathway model named
as palm 2 llm with about 400 billion
plus parameters to take on chat GPD
head-on head in generating responses and
the application codes and
with the details discussed let's move
ahead to some of the important
parameters to be considered to discuss
the differences firstly user interface
and experience chat GPD has a simple and
subtle interface making it easy to
understand and get along with the usage
so chat gpt's user interface looks
something like this chatgpt has a simple
Dark theme interface focusing on
providing users with high quality
language processing capabilities rather
than immersive visuals you can ask
questions get answers and even you can
ask to enhance or optimize the answer
according to your needs again user needs
to manually request chat GPD the other
hand Bing is more inclined towards
giving a blissful visual experience to
their users by choosing brilliant
background images colorful interfaces
and emojis
so a typical Wing user interface looks
something like this in addition to that
it is backed up by chat gpd's dataset
and Prometheus llm to help users with
the best in class answers to their
questions it even delivers three
different answers at the same time
creative balanced and precise are the
three variants and you can choose the
best ones which suits your requests now
lastly but bar is a little different
from others unlike others but just dumps
the answers at once enthusiasts call it
fast but it misses the human touch of
giving the answers in a word by word
typing minor yet similar to Bing it
manages to give you different versions
of the answers besides that but has a
decent interface and its logo shines
with multiple colors giving you the
feeling of part processing the data to
give you a better result now let's try
to ask a few most frequently asked
questions to power chat
let's ask with a simple one are you
friends with
chat GPT and Bing
you can see The Shining logo of Bot and
you have just seen the way how Google
bot answers you it just dumps the answer
now if you go or if you ask the same
question to the other one select charge
gbd and Bing let's see how they respond
and you can see you have other drives as
well right so you can see trap1 graph 2
and draft three so you can choose any
ones which you feel are more optimized
and you know deliverable according to
your requests right now let's go back to
think right now let's ask the same
question
are you friends with
chat GPD
and but
see the word by word typing approach of
Bing and charge APD gave you a little
more immersive feeling that somebody is
really talking to you right and you also
have the freedom of
choosing the answer wisely right so it
gives you three different options which
are creative balanced and precise right
and on just one single scroll you have
the Bing search open here right this is
one other good way of using Bing in the
in case if you have any questions that
are unanswered or which did not satisfy
you you can also go back to Bing and you
can manually search for the data and get
the information right now let's get back
to chat GPD
here let's ask this in question
are you
friends with
Bing and bad
me
so that's how individual AI models
respond to each other and now let's get
back to the next point of discussion
which is what is the data or history
about the questions you asked or the
prompts you have opened that each one of
these stores
so this is about the conversation
history or the prompt that you have with
individual one of these AI models
first comes the chat GPD charge GPD
claims they do not store any data about
its interaction with its users but in
chat GPD you can access the prompts and
questions you asked you can also export
your transcripts in chat GPD on the
other hand we have bing bing says they
do not have any history or prompts of
your previous conversations as well and
lastly but but is a little mix and match
at both so what bar does is it Stores
Only the prompts whereas in chat GPT
when you ask a question it will store
the question and the onsite gave you but
but it will only store The Prompt that
is the question you asked and note the
answer it gave to you
so with that the next point of
discussion would be the mobile version
of each one of these as of now chat jbd
hasn't released any of the official
mobile application version yet and on
the other hand on Bing it has just one
click of a button and you can click it
and then Launches on your mobile phone
and when has a mobile variant with
similar and much better Aesthetics that
can get started on a touch of an app
launcher and lastly we have bought bird
has a similar approach to its mobile
variant Google has enabled part usage in
Google mobile application as well and
now comes the number of questions asked
disclaimer if you want to work on a
project presentation or thesis choose
your AI model wisely because if you are
close to wrapping up your project and
the AI model says sorry pal you're out
of your wishes Yes you heard me right a
few of these language models have a
limitation on the number of questions
asked on one single topic or one single
keyword or one single concept let's look
into details before we proceed to the
next part of this video let's take a
minute to hear from our Learners who
have experienced massive success and
their careers hey I'm Sharia Jaleel I
live in Ontario Canada I have been in
I.T sector for the past 20 years I
recently took the professional
certificate program in artificial
intelligence and machine learning the
course has changed the way I look at
things and helped me back some amazing
freelance projects I started my career
in 1999 and over the years I have worked
with many companies my last tenor was
with IBM Canada my aim was to restart my
carrier and learn something that would
help accelerate my career
I thought artificial intelligence can
make me Future Ready
the course in artificial intelligence
and machine learning is provided by
simply learn in association with Purdue
University which is why I chose the
course I did not have high expectations
from online course but my experience was
simply awesome
quality of interaction within the course
was simply amazing the course faculty
was also very experienced and
knowledgeable
after the course my knowledge has grown
manifold I have immensely benefited from
Python and coding skills I am able to
get some new freelance projects
so I am planning to start
an aib start up with my friend where I
feel that the learning from the course
to be very helpful I am really delighted
and happy
content on YouTube and I talk about new
technologies and what kind of courses
professionals should be taking along
with many other topic I definitely
recommend this course to everyone after
all when it comes to new skills to
advance your career there should be no
compromise you should always learn from
the band
[Music]
first comes chat gbd chat GPD takes 25
questions on a single keyword or a
single subject or a single topic of
discussion post that it refrains from
answering your questions
same with Bing it takes no more than 20
questions on single keyword or a single
topic or a single concept
but now comes Brad
Brad is a little different Brad kind of
said this takes a little too high it
almost has no limits to your questions
you can ask any number of questions to
God and that can be a real deal breaker
lastly we will differentiate these AI
models based on their productivity yes
exactly we do know all these three
models are smart but how smart exactly
how humanly are they how close are they
in convincing you with an optimistic
answer what's their potential to charge
a hypothetical question and give you a
balanced answer sounds interesting right
let's get started first let's start with
chat GPD so let's say I want to learn Ai
and machine learning so obviously this
should be able to teach me that let's
ask it
can you
teach me
artificial intelligence
machine learning
brilliant it gave me a brief about
artificial intelligence machine learning
types of machine learning and deep
learning in one go and it also convince
you here right yes as an AI model I can
certainly help you with that right so
it's a good answer now let's try to ask
a little different one
or
can it plan an itinerary or can it buy
me a product online or can it do some
other things like booking me an Uber
right so let's try 10 new
or change
in line
training program
for
Ai and ml
brilliant charge GPA knows its limits
right as an AI model I cannot directly
purchase online right it's giving you
the brutal truth here that's good and
apart from that it also gave you a
step-by-step procedure
for buying your course to your research
check the curriculum check the
instructor what's the format what's the
cause right a few parameters which you
might want to consider before buying a
course right so now let's try to
question the same queries to Wing So
since Bing and chat GPT share the same
training data set I could expect a
similar answer but let's see it is
taking a while I guess Prometheus is a
little
slower compared to GPT okay there might
be a connection issue let's ask the
question once again
wow it's way too better than charge EVD
so it is even asking you details on if
you if you are looking for a specific
topic or a general overview let's say I
would need a general overview
I could straight away say Bing is a
little more smarter and productive
compared to chat jpd but still we have
one more Contender to compare with but
right
so there might be again the internet
connection
now let's say we refresh Bing once again
and straight away ask the second
question what we had right that is can
you buy me a course
online course
for learning
artificial
thing did gave me a good answer for the
previous question let's see what kind of
an answer it gives me now I'm sorry but
I'm not capable of making online
purchases however I can find you some
online courses for learning AI would you
like me to search for some options
brilliant
so this is a little more optimized
answer compared to chat GPD ones and it
is also honest it does know its limits
fine it can help you search for some
online courses but again a chart GPD
gave us some parameters to consider
right so I would give or I would choose
to tie them up here they are on a tie
now our last Contender that is part
let's try to ask the same questions to
Bart so here is bad now let's try to ask
questions too but let's say can you
teach me
in learning
you can see the bad logo shining there
now it should be dumping the answer
anytime soon yeah of course we do miss
that humanly Touch of giving the answer
in a word by word typing way
let's refresh and ask the question again
can you teach me
this is a little too straightforward I'm
a language model and don't have the
capacity to help you out
so
okay let's not give up here let's try to
ask the second question can you purchase
an online
training program
to me
to learn
machine learning
yes I can help you purchase an online
program for machine learning here are a
few things that you need to consider
good
it's not being brutally honest here it
is saying it can help you out so again
what I intended to expect here was you
cannot just directly buy an online
program right you need some details
credentials and everything to purchase
so again it is the answer and it is
definitely giving you suggestions
similar to chat GPD but a little
different which focuses on your learning
style level of experience your budget
good nice way to answer some questions
like this one so all these three ones
are brilliant and good in their own way
so it might be a little difficult to
declare host the winner as of now since
the bad AI model is going to switch to
Palm 2 and we are expecting some updates
to each one of these with that we can
consider currently they are standing
next to each other with similar
capabilities and better enhancement in
different fields so with that having
said we can conclude this session on
chat GPD versus Bling versus bot and if
you would like me to answer the
conclusion I would say well it seems
like we all have our strengths and
weaknesses at the end of the day it
comes to word users value the most that
they want a visually appealing interface
strong privacy protections or the
ability to converse with an AI language
model it's up to them to decide so you
are the viewers and you can decide the
winner of this particular battle on chat
gbd versus Bing versus bad and with that
having said if you are an aspiring
artificial intelligence engineer looking
for online training and certifications
from the prestigious universities and in
collaboration with leading experts so
that you have the most robust
foundations skills knowledge and what it
takes to become the best then search no
more simply launch postgraduate program
and artificial intelligence from Caltech
University in collaboration with IBM
should be your right choice for more
details use the links in the description
box below with that we have come to an
end of this session and if you have any
queries regarding any of the topics
coupled in this session or if you have
any other points that we must discuss in
this session then please do let us know
in the comment section below and let us
know which AI model is your preference
or you declare as the winner of this
particular battle
until next time thank you stay safe
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learning YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here